um I think I think I highlighted one of
my orbs one of my summer I highlighted
in her she's she is so do you guys
um
because one of the questions I had was
Andrew has Andrew Tate snitched on
himself and admitted to being guilty in
Hustler's university courses and I know
you guys touched on that a bit earlier
but
um it seemed like you guys almost agree
that it could have been in Grandeur but
then you kind of were going back and
forth I personally think he has but his
issue was that hasn't been the evidence
of some brought in front of the court so
far I don't know what the prosecution is
ultimately going to end up bringing up
sometimes these investigations start
small and they end up sprawling back to
a lot of things but you couldn't convict
Andrew Tate based on what he said on
social media that can only be a starting
point for an investigation if you find
something then you maybe you know bring
charges for it but you can't just
convict them based on the course okay
see you guys so we we agree on that but
my only question two is Destiny do you
agree that if there's a scenario that
what he said online
is different to the allegations that
can't be used
what if what so what he said online can
never be used against him that would
only be a tool for investigators to
further dig into what he said so he
agrees online stuff is not
and then you sort of agree on the psych
report too right uh I would have to see
specifically why she's extrapolating
that to the other victims I don't
remember her rationale for why she uh
could make claims about the other piece
of uh person's State of Mind
okay so yes or no so no
I'm agnostic on it right now okay well
yeah no no come on it's not about
winning the argument Destiny do you
think let's just let's frame it like
this then because you like you said you
need to look into it
if I did a psych report on Pearl based
on your statement do you think that's do
you think that's I wouldn't trust your
interpretation of it and I've only read
articles I'm not saying that I'm not
saying but I'm not even gonna follow the
analogy because like for instance the
analogy that you made about her
trafficking me just because I came here
to cam shows that you either have no
idea what trafficking is or what so I
know you've not approved it so I would
never no one has proved it yet if it was
proven that he would be convicted
exactly right because so in terms of I I
would have to I've only read articles
summarizing the second ever read the
secret for myself no no you don't
understand because you don't want to
answer it because it basically says
no no because it's a defeater because
the whole point is this you're saying
you've not looked into it so you don't
have the knowledge about it I'm saying
this happened and I'm saying that's fine
you may not be able to take my word for
it my question to you is in the
hypothetical where person ear is deemed
a person by speaking to person a you
decide that person B has severe mental
issues always brainwashed or whatever it
may be do you think that's acceptable
depends on the commonalities that you
find between the two
how would you determine the
commonalities
um let's say you did a psych report on
somebody and let's say that you found
that this person worked for Andrew Tate
for five years this person had a tattoo
saying owned by Tate um this person was
recruited in a similar method and then
talked to them you realize like this
person's ability to even talk to him
talk to the um talk to person a not b
okay you talk to person a and you figure
all of that out about person a you're
like this person's ability to understand
the situation they've been in is
severely compromised and then you look
at person B and you start to find all of
those commonalities then it might be
fair to extrapolate how would you know
about them commonalities I don't know
what their what her method of data
collection
okay well that's up to the prosecution
to present at trial I guess or present
to the trash yeah yeah so again another
problem well I don't know if it's a
problem or not we have it it depends on
if it goes to quarter it's a severe
problem bro come on what are you gonna
say if this goes to court and all of
this evidence plus more is brought in
front of the judge if this goes to court
and that that means there's Beyond
evidence which is beyond Reasonable
Doubt and then we look at the evidence
and it actually isn't some kind of like
you know where they're trying to
basically do the guys over
then yeah I would accept it I would
accept any evidence so if there's
actually unequivocal evidence that these
guys have done these crimes of course we
would accept it that's that would be
illogical and you would be basically
um a Stan if you basically said no
matter what it's not for example I
didn't agree when a lot of the tear
people who send the audience were fake
because I knew they weren't but what
happened was there was a um in terms of
the vice piece but what actually
happened was it snipped out the other
side of the conversation so we don't
just make Arguments for the sake of it
I'm basing it solely on what I'm seeing
and I to be honest it looks like in this
whole thing I know you don't want to
accept certain points and you're doing
it quite
um with
um
um you know without finding how to agree
um in reality we kind of agree on
everything you agree that online stuff
can be used we agree the psych report is
problematic we agree right now there's
only reasonable suspicion that they need
to find more evidence to get it to be on
reasonable doubt we agree
um that the do you agree that CCTV
evidence should be included uh depends
on what charges they want to bring forth
do you think the CCTV evidence should be
included come on depends on what charges
human trafficking can rip that's what I
don't know if that evidence is
dispositive
whether it's positive or negative do you
agree that that evidence would would
help find out that's why I said I don't
know if it's dispositive I don't know if
that evidence would go against claims
that they were being trafficked even
though the CCTV this is enough of the
life and of the entire facility to show
that like oh look they could leave at
any time were there people leaving the
premises that were employed for them
that were going in and out on that CTT
evidence well why why don't the one
include it there's a reason they don't
want I'm asking you what's there sorry
what was in the CCTV footage that you
think was some point yeah so according
to the witness Jasmine what the what is
actually shown in the CCTV evidence is
that they had freedom of movement that
the girl was basically jogging regularly
wait Freedom a moment how that for
example the woman was one of the victims
allegedly was what walk the running
government runs on her own so okay so if
she was the evidence she was part of the
evidence was leaked by The Prostitute
part of the evidence that was leaked by
the prosecution were text messages
saying that uh they were not allowed to
leave the premises that anytime they
wanted to leave they had to take one of
the two bodyguards or the um the one
lady the police officer I think lady
that was one of the texts yeah so again
so that what's up message you're talking
about was a snippet so if you look at it
it was like three texts and again so
that's the argument of the team that put
the whole what's up in because this
whole thing and everybody's an advice
everybody's in a BBC where you do
Snippets you can convict and you I can
convict I'll give you the example where
I can connect to you based on a snippet
of you see making that comment the issue
is this that you do the whole piece so
if someone saw your 10 hour podcast you
didn't say that you literally saying the
opposite but if I snip that bit I could
say you know what you're a racist the
issue is this you give the whole of the
WhatsApp and then that's how you decide
in terms of the CCTV what it shows
according to Jasmine one of the alleged
victims who says I'm not a victim and
she's saying that it shows that one of
the alleged victims not her used to
regularly jog on her own that shows
freedom of movement one of the important
aspects of human trafficking is that you
don't have freedom of movement that
breaks one example of breaking the human
traffic allegation the finances breaks
the allegation of human trafficking the
reason I brought these up is because
they break the human traffic allegation
so the CCTV why is it the defense is so
adamant it should be included
sure so for finances
um I'm pretty sure that I don't know
what you're saying that anything for
proof of Finance is everything that has
ever been talked about or really seems
to show that the finance are in control
of the tapes that's what I've heard said
over and over and over again um in terms
of jogging um Jasmine might have stated
that somebody jogged but I don't know if
she said that under oath I don't know if
that's been entered into like an
official like witness statement now
maybe it will come when they go to the
court case where that'll actually be
argued about but my understanding is
that I don't think you have to publish
every single piece of evidence you have
before you go to trial for any country
ever right no no you may publicly
published I don't know if you have to
publicly publish
for I imagine for the court they're
probably only pushing as much as they
need to so for the call you need to give
the evidence and I've just cited we
didn't have all the evidence yes every
piece of evidence you found you have to
give to the job yeah because it's just
enough to show that you have a
reasonable suspicion that your
investigation will no because you need
to demonstrate to the judge that
basically you're gonna you have got the
evidence to demonstrate that what you've
got so in reality what they need to show
is that they've got evidence right now
because that shows that they will be
able to get Beyond Reasonable Doubt
because if the but the problem is they
haven't got the evidence right now so
that's why they're looking for evidence
so I don't think that everything we
agree that they don't need that evidence
right you don't need evidence to hold
somebody for up to 180 days for that
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt sorry you
don't need the evidence
yeah yeah I agree with that because for
the 180 days you need Reasonable
Suspicion what the judges said is when
you've given me the evidence that
evidence only amounts to Reasonable
Suspicion that's the reason they
investigating and looking unless they're
basically basically violating their
rights and keeping them for 180 days to
break them before they say guess what
now we've got new evidence but in
reality we've seen it they're doing
raids they're finding new women them to
them for women that you refer to have
just been found very recently we have to
look at their backstory look at whether
it works so this is not information that
they held on to and then and then
thought you know what we're going to use
a they're looking for evidence so what
the problem is this they've been looking
for evidence for 10 months and they've
only got a reasonable suspicion they're
not given the CCTV evidence because it's
quite clear any reasonable person I know
it's your job to debate so I respect
that you're doing a very good job
because your position you're starting
from a very weak position so you've done
brilliant but the thing is
the the evidence is very clear that it
doesn't amount to that level so when you
look at it there's a issue with CCTV why
they're not putting it there's an issue
with the psych report there's an issue
with the level of evidence there is
there's an issue in terms of the
information that is being leaked to the
Press which is Snippets or the fact that
they're not put in the long form of a
WhatsApp WhatsApp either to the judge or
in in if they're going to leak and leak
it properly but but they're not even
including it when they give it to
digital so I think that all of that
demonstrates and this is the reason why
when looking at all the information and
even looking at the specific rape
allegations because we've not gotten
into that but this if you look at the
story of the U.S woman you look at the
story of the UK moldovan woman who's
from UK
their stories don't add up there's a
huge problems there's huge issues with
their stories so even the rape
allegations do not stand up and hence
why the judge said you need more
evidence how are they going to find more
evidence
after 10 months whether or not found it
let's be reasonable we know they're not
going to find any more evidence for that
specific allegation in terms of human
trafficking
they've got these they've got these
allegations the judge said go back and
find some more evidence right now they
haven't got the evidence they may find
it and that's not what I'm denying but
that's what they're looking for so
they're in a Race Against Time to find
the evidence
and anybody whose entity is claiming
that look we have got that you know
they're gonna go down but the problem is
as reasonable rational people who
analyze information the evidence isn't
there and I think
um to be honest this whole debate we've
just we've come to an agreement about
everything so
I don't know what else to say yeah I
think that the judge right now feels
like there's compelling enough evidence
that a an investigation
compelling enough evidence that the
investigation is going to turn up
something that's going to lead to
charges you're not allowed to just hold
them there on nothing so he's seen
enough he that's what he's felt that's
why he's denied their repeals repeatedly
um and all we could do is wait and see
what charges actually get brought
against them but until then it's all
just speculation do you agree there's
enough evidence to hold them right now
yes there is enough evidence based on
Reasonable Suspicion to hold them but he
doesn't look out of the Romanians yeah
but but
you think that the court is violating
international law right by not by not
because they're not include but they're
not including the CCT yeah and a few
other things yeah and in terms of the
reasonable suspicion
another problem is this that what
they've done is to hold them for 180
days is a very extreme measure as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible